- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is follow your own dreams.
Over to you PewDiePie.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
♫ I wake up ever morning
- Follow your own goddamn dreams.
Not what your mom wants you to do,
not what your dad wants you to do,
not what you think you should be doing,
but doing what you want
to do more than anything.
It's been said so many times before,
but really, if you don't make
your own decisions in life,
someone else is going
to make them for you,
and by the end of it, you won't be happy.
So you might as well do
what it is you want to do.
- So I think somewhere along the lines,
in everyone's life, you
have to make the decision
at some point, whether you
are living your version
of your life, or someone
else's version of your life.
Because along the way,
people are always going
to have opinions on what
you should and shouldn't do.
They're going to have opinions
on what career you should take,
have opinions on what
school you should go to,
have opinions on whether to
start that business or not,
to move to that country or not,
have opinions on what color
socks you're going to wear today.
People will have opinions on everything.
And if all you do is live your life
according to other people's
opinions and expectations,
you are never going to
get to the point where
one, you're happy, and two,
you're actually doing the thing
that you can be great at.
It's not going to happen.
Now, in the early days
of being a human being,
you listen to your parents, right?
You go to the classes and
schools that they send you to
and you listen to them, and
hopefully you're a little bit
respectful, as well.
But as you get older, at some point,
you need to realize that
you're an adult human being.
And you need to make decisions
and take accountability
for your life, as well.
If you're not where you want to be,
if you're in the wrong major,
if you're taking the wrong classes,
if you're in the wrong
business or wrong career,
it's not your parents' fault,
it's not your friends' fault,
it's not your advisor's fault.
It's your own fault.
You, that's it, it's your fault.
You are where you are
because of you, period.
You can't blame other
people for your decisions
for the rest of your life.
So if you want to break free,
you have to take that responsibility
and start doing something about it.
I find that you're going
to have two kinds of people
who will be the haters in your life.
The people who will
give you the bad advice,
the wrong advice, the unsupportive advice.
The first group is going to be the people
who are jealous of you.
The people who are just nasty people,
haters of the little man, and
they tell you all the reasons
why you can't do the
thing that you want to do.
You want to go and start that business,
they tell you how you
don't have the education,
the connections, and the
money, and the resources,
and you've never done them before,
and who are you to think
you can go out and do that.
No one from this town has ever gone on
and done something that big.
All of those people.
And often, if you look at their life,
it's really just based out of fear,
insecurity, and jealousy.
Maybe at one point, they took a big shot,
they tried to follow their dream,
they tried to do something important,
and it didn't work out.
And because they didn't have success,
now nobody around them can have success.
Now every idea or everybody
who tries to do something
on their own, that's a bad idea,
and they need to be the anchor
for everybody around them.
Right?
You're trying to rise up, and
they want to pull you back down.
They're going to be
that anchor around you.
And those are the easier
people, actually, to ignore.
Their words may sting,
they may be more visceral
and more angry with you,
but recognizing that they
haven't done the thing
that you want to do makes it easier.
It's now the second
group who are the people
who are doing it out of love.
They're not doing it out
of fear and jealousy,
they're doing it out of love.
You know, your parents may tell you
not to go out and start that business,
not to go out and chase
that dream of yours.
Your closest friends may
tell you that's really risky.
Don't go out and do that.
And they're doing it out of love,
because they care about you.
It's not that they're
jealous or they hate you.
They love you.
The challenge is, they see success,
success through their eyes,
through their narrow, limited view, right?
And success may be go out
and get a safe, secure job.
Go out and be a doctor, be an
accountant, or be a lawyer.
Go out and do this safe thing.
Or, do what I did, right?
I went and I did this and I had success,
so you should follow in my footsteps,
because that's what success looks like.
And the way to break
through is understanding
that your version of success
does not look like theirs.
And what really helps is to think about,
these people that are giving me advice,
my parents, the people
around me, the haters,
these people that are
throwing opinions on me,
who are telling me all these
things that I should be doing
that I'm not, have they
done what you want to do?
Have they gone where you want to go?
And if the answer is no, then who are they
to give you advice?
How can they tell you what to do
if they've never done what you want to do?
If anything, you want to take
the opposite of their advice.
I don't want your life, and
so I'm going to go this way
and do the opposite of
what you're telling me.
Now, you don't have to be mean
and rude and in their face
about it, especially if
it's coming from a place
of love from them.
But in your head, that's
what you're thinking.
These people have not done
what I'm trying to do.
They don't know how to give me the advice
to help me get there.
I need to find different mentors,
different guides, a different path,
that is different from
what they're telling me.
And if you shrink down
and you don't accept that
and you say, "You know
what, you guys are right,"
because you're afraid to stand up to them,
then you're never ever
ever ever going to reach
your potential, never.
You're never going to be fully happy.
You're always going to wonder what if.
You're always going to think
that you could be doing more.
And the longer you stay on that path,
the more boxed in and
boxed in and boxed in
you're going to get.
And you've built a life for yourself
where it's okay to shrink down.
Where it's okay to play the smaller game
and just live inside this box.
Where every time you get
challenged by anybody,
you've conditioned yourself to shrink down
and just accept that
that's the way life is.
And you're now going to
teach this to others.
You're going to teach
this to your friends.
You're going to teach this to your kids.
You're going to teach playing
small and limited thinking
onto the next generation, to your kids.
And I want that cycle of
mediocrity to stop with you.
I want you to practice being bold.
I want you to practice
listening to yourself,
understanding what you're all about
and what your dreams are.
When you have an idea,
you start, you go for it,
you push it forward.
I want you to be a source of inspiration
for the people around you.
Where you don't need to yell
at them and show them off
and tell them how they're wrong.
You're just going to go
out and do your thing.
And you may fail in the early days,
but if you stick out and you persevere,
you're going to have success.
And that will be an inspiration
to the people around you, saying,
"Look what he's doing."
"Look what she's doing, huh.
"I can do something, too."
That's what I want for you.
And I hope you want it for yourself, too.
Believe.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what was the hardest part
about living your own dreams?
What was the hardest part?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Reynaldo Espinoza
from selfbuiltempire.com.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, it really,
really, really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of an espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
Hey Believe Nation, we're
also look at doing a Top 10
on PewDiePie, and here is a sneak peek
at some of the clips we're
thinking about using.
I hope you enjoy the bonus.
- See how many spoons you
can balance on your face.
What's the point of this?
My job is so easy, I can
literally do what I feel like.
It's kind of amazing, just
the fact that I can play
video games for a living.
And when I realized
that for the first time,
like I was almost getting teary-eyed.
Like it was my dream has come true.
♫ All this time I've been finding myself
♫ And I didn't know I was lost
I'd be happy not to be
number one. (laughs)
I'm just a nerd who plays video games.
I didn't seek the spotlight.
Your parents will tell you you can be
whatever you want to be
in life, which is true.
But what a lot of times
they don't tell you
is that you have to work
really hard to get there.
And another thing, maybe more importantly,
is that you have to take risks.
You have to venture into the unknown,
and you might not know
what's going to happen,
and that's scary.
But I think it's always
better to try than not try,
no matter what.
Except meth, not even once.